[Musique]
améliorer les conditions de vie des
familles réunionnaises en leur proposant
des logements épanouissants et le cœur
des priorités définies dans la
convention cadre signé ce mardi 4 avril
au Palais de la source le département
est le groupe CDC habitat s'engage à
travers ce partenariat lui répondre aux
besoins de logement des ménages
réunionnais ce partenariat va nous
permettre d'avancer pour plus rapidement
dans un certain nombre de domaines
notamment par exemple de l'axe l'accès
la propriété c'est important parce que
le département met en place des
dispositifs pour les familles qui le
souhaitent et bien vaccès décès habitat
l'accès sur la propriété
sera renforcée vous avez aussi tout ce
qui touche à la réhabilitation des
logements les plus anciens notamment
pour nos publics les plus fragiles les
personnes âgées personne porteuses
handicap ou là ce sont des enveloppes de
10000 euros qui sont prévus pour
permettre à ces décès habitats
d'améliorer justement le logement des
familles les plus modestes et puis il y
a toute la tout le programme je dirais
de construction
de logement neuf un partenariat qui
souhaite mettre en place des solutions
innovantes pour répondre aux défis
environnementaux il y a aussi tout le
chapitre du développement du logement
sur l'île de la Réunion et le
développement qui intègre une dimension
aussi environnementale forte une
dimension de développement durable pour
produire en fait des logements de
qualité mais adaptés aussi voilà au
changement climatique qu'on peut vivre
aujourd'hui en fait de produire un
habitat durable et accessible à tous
Voilà c'est vraiment nous notre mission
c'est des habitats et ainsi d'air
pour janikaccia pas président du conseil
d'administration de la SDR il est
également important de développer
l'accès aux droits des familles
réunionnaises les familles qui y sont de
les logements de la sidea peuvent
prétendre à des aides mais elles ne sont
pas suffisamment informés et nous avons
avec le Conseil départemental mis en
place donc une application qui va
permettre de diffuser l'ensemble des
aides et permettre aux familles de
pouvoir accéder rapidement ces
informations et le cas échéant
évidemment de bénéficier d'aide
supplémentaires on parle de en moyenne
de 110 euros dont ce serait privé les
familles par absence d'information et
donc là Sid a le département vont
travailler de de
la main pour que les familles puissent
bénéficier de tous les droits
une convention cadre qui vise à
améliorer la qualité de vie des
habitants de La Réunion
[Musique]